and Greg you want to fight no flash fans
are outraged want every Miller gone
immediately from the DCE you we're gonna
react to loopers video to get all the
information I followed some of the news
so far is it real was it a joke was it a
joke gone too far this title is not
surprising but let's see what's in store
and then we'll talk some more an
incident involving ACTA Azra millicent
funds of DC superhero movies into a
frenzy on April 6th a video started
circulating in the media that appears to
show Miller choking a female fan before
dragging her to the ground more many
initially thought the footage might be
of junk has been confirmed as being
genuine according to the rioting in
Reykjavik Iceland which Miller who uses
Vey them pronouns reportedly frequents
when visiting the Icelandic capital the
establishments owner added that the
actor had to be escorted out of the bar
afterwards the incident took place on
April 1st waving their arms around his
oh she's dancing or mock fighting with
the actor Miller can be heard saying oh
you want to fight that's what you want
to do to the young woman before grabbing
her by the throat the video is only
seven seconds long and Kurt's thousands
of women is thrown to the ground
bystanders can be heard trying to defuse
the situation Miller who has a featured
role as Creedence barebone in the
fantastic beasts franchise has played
the flash in the DC EU films they were
first cast on the role as a Scarlet
speedster for a cameo appearance in
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice before
appearing in Justice League Miller made
another cameo as a DC EU version of
Barry Allen in a CW's arrow adverse
crossover events crisis on Infinite
Earths
Miller is currently slated to reprise
her role once again in a flash solo
feature which is due in 2032 following
the multiple delays but some funds have
sounded a very vocal call for the actors
immediate removal from the solo film
work to be directed by Ed Helmer and EB
sketti most feel that Grant Gustin who
was played by E for six years on the
reverse series the flash is a better
representative for the iconic character
though the fans have taken to Twitter
and droves to call for Miller's removal
one user suggested that fans should set
up a petition to get rid of Miller from
the DCE oh yeah petitions always working
of the actor playing the flash on
television rather than having a go at
Miller one fan tweeted after hearing all
this Ezra Miller business it got me
thinking it won't be so dope of crime to
Gustin played flash in the DCE you just
give him a movie budget costume as a
complete rewrite of his character it's
perfect another added a similar
suggestion tweeting Grant Gustin is
talented a dork has the biggest heart is
the best Barry Allen and most
importantly never attacked anyone
Twitter account dr movie news - further
pleating if there's one positive to come
out of that insane Ezra Miller video
it's not Warner Brothers may finally
have the chance to recast them and find
someone good to play Barry Allen flash
vamoose sketchy solo movie and have it
be separate from the DCE you like the
Batman yeah actually seeing in the video
because it wasn't a person behind the
camera starts filming no one seems to
know one calls to Miller's apparently
extreme reaction because of one the
video cuts
listen clear what happened afterwards
eyewitnesses told variety that the group
of fans have approached quite pushy and
that things escalated from there some
fans believe that the call for Miller's
dismissal from the upcoming projects is
to Russia response to a seven second
clip with not a lot of context
surrounding it one individual tweeted
people are too quick to jump and cancel
Ezra Miller over a video about which no
one has any context yet what you can see
what really happened but I'm also not
defending them according to scream ran
to the person
posted a video with a friend of the
woman in the clip and she claimed that
her friend was jokingly challenging
Miller to a fight which Miller then took
to seriously her friend descends to lead
to that only her reddit post but also
her entire Twitter profile but not
before people were able to get
screenshots of her explanation of the
incident
neither Miller their representatives or
Warner Brothers immediately released the
statement regarding the video why not
they're probably still figuring out how
the most suspicious thing about it is
the fact that Azra Miller hasn't said
anything about it because there's
nothing do you remember on Jimmy Kimmel
when it's not the same thing at all
Jimmy Kimmel when Joaquin Phoenix had
that I had that lead clip of him
behaving irrationally on set and
everyone was like Jimmy Kimmel of was
rude did it up that was confirmed the
publicist came out and said it was fake
I listened to interviewer Joaquin
Phoenix they did a podcast with his
sisters and he said it was fake they
came out and said it was fake yeah
while there's of this argument going on
with Ezra Miller I don't have a side I
think it was stupid nonetheless yeah
like it's does suit it's incredibly dumb
there are these reports coming at night
you just never know really what to
believe anymore because people want to
jump in on the conversation of like they
had to be escorted out he spit on a
bartender he's known to be a very rude
individual I don't know I was from
Miller I've never even seen him
interview with the guy from being on his
side I have no idea exactly who he is
like the fact that they he has been
incredibly hush about the whole
situation
just makes it that much more suspicious
I could see it having been a joke gone
too far where someone's egging him on
and he starts choking her but pushes her
down I hear someone in the camera going
bro or something like that some people
are poor they try to get him off like
the joke gone way too far
but even if you're joking like dude
don't do that don't do that don't you
know your position in the world at this
point you know bad this could be like
misconstrued even before the whole
mewtwo movement at all that this would
already be a terrible look most of us
learn this like in elementary school yes
we all play fightin and go to farm early
is probably a bad idea yeah if it is a
joke gone too far I feel like there's
some wiggle room to debate here actually
about whether or not we should just get
his remover out of the DCE you you know
was it Ezra Miller who got provoked and
genuinely got mad and then did that
still badly I mean that's it doesn't
even worse it doesn't look that way like
from the 7 seconds like how looper has
pointed out it's only a 7 second clip
from the look of it I would assume it
was a bit gone too far still the fact
that it's been completely quieted that
is not healthy and it makes me I mean
obviously makes you wonder why is it
like are they talking to all of his
various people and trying to figure out
what their plan is based off of just him
or they figuring out what is gonna
happen with DC and Harry Potter before
they you know come out with something
public but I don't know the thing to me
having seen the clip several times and
again this is just speculation but he
sounds drunk to me like the way he is
fight you know like he sounds kind of
strung out and even his body language
when he takes her down
looks a little lung key looks like he's
not very well in control so even that
even if it is just like a joke + sloppy
drunk it's still bad like that and it's
like you maybe want to go to rehab or
something which is a becoming a weird
thing of the DCE and why isn't he
practicing social distancing well yeah
they first heard a barn iceland like
with fans getting like touching that's
the other thing as people said April 1st
yeah it could be an April Fool's joke
that there's been going out there was
terrible joke ins way past April 1st
yes on April 3rd yeah and then there's a
flipside was just a movie discussion of
oh let's replace him I thought Ezra
Miller was one of the best parts of the
Justice League movie some people really
didn't like that portrayal regardless of
that the idea of getting Grant Gustin
there now well I think Rec Grant Gustin
is perfect that's a whole other
discussion at this point now cuz then it
creates a whole other kind of film you
got a gonna work around and then now at
that point it's like I don't agree
you have to completely rewrite Barry
Allen and give him a completely
different character but then again with
what crisis on Infinite Earths did
connecting all the shows and movies
explaining multiple universes it could
just be Grant Gustin playing Barry Allen
again but a different Barry Allen on a
different universe
you're still rebooting the flash inside
of the movie verse they sawed off Grant
Gustin playing Barry Allen in that world
that's one approach you can do to it I
feel like it could be a little too
convoluted and difficult to work with
then again you could just have Barry
Allen from the flash of the show cast
cameo in the flash movie with Grant
Gustin in there similar to how they had
Ezra Miller had like a one-minute cameo
in the Crescent and the earth
immediately going the movies are now
connected yeah so you could just do that
either way it's or Bellary dress this
man you can't just go on silent forever
I'm really curious as to what that is
gonna be and also this makes me wonder
because we've had a lot of other shows
with beloved you know poor trails people
talking about bring them to the movies
this is a situation that has like
extraneous outside circumstance so it
makes me wonder who will be the first
from one of these TV use and versus to
get boosted up into a movie I'm not
saying it's definitely gonna be Grant
Gustin but you know maybe that's gonna
be an interesting day for the you know
superhero movie landscape anyway yeah
sure what's your take on this Ezra
Miller situation I don't think it's
right to just presume it was a joke we
need actual clarity of the situation
because probation till we got facts
bottom line don't hurt women you know
that opening bit was a bit there was a
pillow underneath her head damage
performed on a closed track with a
professional stunt I didn't actually
have my eyes on her throat only my hands
all right but she likes to be choked
whatever subscribe notification hatred a
shout out
JT John take it away I wrote a little
story for you just think about JT why
just today I was thinking of JT JT
juicing a tomato judiciously talking
from his jaws taunting me like a gesture
terribly I miss JT justifiably tense was
he the Dave John came to town for a
jaunt and a tryst jeez you tease Sanjay
with tenacity jeepers said I take it
easy but just then John Travolta and
Justin Timberlake jumped down from a
tree flanked by jennifer Tilly and Josh
Trank jabbing in us with tongue Hawks
ready to jettison us and take our lunch
money but just think of the brave one JT
jumping into the thick of a jousting
tournament like a jackal tearing and
jamming twisting and shaping and
jubilant - was JT upon jacking up the
last of these Tinseltown jag-offs he
turned to John today you were my job he
said justice and tutelage and so JT and
John's triste jubilant at the top was
jostled into something tremendous
teaching juxtaposed with high
temperatures and JT goes for the jugular
like a Jaguars tooth of the talons of a
Jay and he's Jewish - love you JT I can
see why that took you 45 minutes now